hello welcome to unit one of intro to
agroecology this unit's entitled current
non-sustainable agriculture practices
what we'll be covering in this unit is
what currently is happening in farming
and why we need to make some changes uh
as we go into the future in able to in
order to be able to um feed the
population of uh the
world uh here is just a picture of way
back when of what the farming practices
were like and basically the reason this
picture is here to show you how um they
used to plow the land and it was just
all open all the time you can see right
now nothing's growing um this would be
in a dormant time probably in the late
fall winter or early spring before we
planted and it's just to show you that
that's what they used to do and we'll
talk as we go on in this uh unit and
discuss some of the changes we need to
make um some of the areas we're going to
look at we're going to look at the
current practices um that we currently
do in agriculture we're going to look at
how we work the land that's the tillage
practices that we use currently and
we'll talk a little bit about um from
the beginning um when they started out
with the Prairies and made them into
Farmland um to today and and the
differences in philosophies and why they
did that um we're going to talk about
synthetic fertilizers and why they have
become an issue and why we need to
change into organic fertilizers we're
going to talk a little bit about um weed
and Pest Control practices that are in
use today um that we use and most of
those are synthetic um not organic and
we'll talk about why we need to change
those too um we'll also talk about a
change that used to be all small family
farms and it's becoming more and more as
time goes on um large corporations doing
the farming and raising the animals and
we'll talk about um why that's been good
and bad and then we'll talk about some
of the limitations we have with our
current
practices um as we go forward in the
future and why we need to change in
order to be able to feed
everyone um the first area we'll talk
about is the um tillage practices that
are in use today um basically when they
had the native prairies you had to um
they called it busting the Prairie but
you were actually taking a piece of
equipment um and making sure that it
could dig into the land and they used to
do that every year and we found out that
in the practices of doing that where
we're losing some uh a lot of soil
because of erosion the winds in the
winter time because was open like that
first picture we saw in this unit um
we're going to look at some of the
different pieces they've used um current
or they're currently using um and we're
going to talk a little bit about why did
they changeed and and uh over the last
50 years into using new practices one of
the reasons they changed was because of
the Dust Bowl they had um that they
found out that the reason they had the
Dust Bowl was because we were plowing
and we were leaving the fields open and
uh prone to being able to have erosion
the wind was blowing the soil everywhere
uh except where wanted it to be um then
we're going to look also at some of the
conservation things that they've come
about probably starting in the late 60s
early 70s to
today um and why did they why are they
practicing it why is the farm bureaus
that are out there helping people or
helping the current Farmers learn that
they need to change what they're doing
uh and then up to the current where
we're pretty much now most farmers are
believing that no till is the way they
should do versus breaking the Prairie or
using the plow all the time um there's a
lot of farmers that don't even have
plows anymore but basically what the no
till is is they've changed when they
plant they've added um some equipment to
it that makes them able to plant and you
know open the ground a little bit but
we're doing it a lot less than what we
did and it's um actually uh saving uh
the land that we
have um some of the current uh tillage
methods that we have there's
cultivation um and what cultivation is
is after the plants are planted they go
in there and they try to control the
weeds so they can do that up to a
certain point um let's just it doesn't
matter whether it's corn or soy beans
the two most common crops that are out
there for most Farmers um it's just a
little they call a chisel plow it's a
v-shaped piece of equipment and what
happens is it just goes between the rows
of the crops whether it's corn or
soybeans and it actually um pulls the
weeds out of the ground you can only do
that till it gets about a foot high but
then at that point the crop tends to
crowd out um the ability for the sun to
get to the ground which is how seeds
germinate for weeds and you don't have
that problem anymore or certainly not as
much um plowing is the first time when
you do it if you've never farmed land or
if you had it let's say in pasture land
or it was just bow which means you don't
have have any crops on it at all that um
you might have to work it with a plow uh
in order to be able to plant again
dising is a practice that's not used as
much anymore but basically it used to be
used all the time in the 60s and 70s
that they go in right before they
planted it's a round shaped saucer and
there's a bunch of them hooked down
we'll have a picture of it later uh to
see it and basically it would it would
uh turn the ground a few inch is in and
provide for the ability to be able to
plant easy um minimum till was when you
would do it
um not as often they got to a point
where they they did not at the end of
the year when they took the crops out
the crop residue was there they used to
always either come in and disc it or
they turn it with a plow for the winter
time and then they come in and disc in
the spring and you'd be able to plant
and they'd have a smooth surface to
plant on now what they do is they leave
that residue a lot of what they found
out will go away in the winter time from
the freeze Tha Cycles uh and then
there's now no till when they started
adding that uh extra it's just a little
disc actually it'll just open the soil
enough to put the seed in the ground and
that's what they call no till so it's
technically it is a little bit of
tilling but it's not as much as it was
when you used to do the
discing
um um on this slide this just goes to
the I said about cultivation plowing and
discing um it talks a little bit more
detail for the cultivation removing
those weeds and it um why does it create
a better growing environment because if
there's less um competition for the
plants the plants are going to do better
they're all competing for excuse me all
the nutrients and water so the less
plants that are there and the ones that
you want that are there they're going to
grow better for you um plowing it'll dig
down in 10 to 12 Ines so you you can see
um that digging down that far how you're
opening up a a big area when it turns
over and you'll see a picture of it in a
little bit that that's what allows for
that erosion when the wind comes to have
it Blow around um pretty much now it's
only used when you're preparing a new
field um dising told you before it's a
platter like device uh it only goes in
46 in and it really doesn't turn it like
a plow it just kind of cut cuts it apart
because of how the disc is and basically
when there are some Farmers that still
do it they'll do it at the end to
harvest to to break apart the corn or
soybean residue that's there um and
basically corn fields are what they use
it in the soybeans don't leave as much
residue okay uh some Farmers still use
it for when they plant a new crop
because that's what they've always done
we all get in habits the minimum till
it's that um discing a fuel before you
plant but you don't ever use plowing at
all um um and I would say most farmers
are either in minimum till or no till um
I'd say vast majority probably 90 to 95%
today across the US um no till is when
they don't use the
um the disc or plow and they go ahead
and harvest plant and harvest without
doing that but once again the planter
that they use has a little disc on that
opens it up enough that you can plant
the seed in the ground
um here's a picture of discing and you
can see it's pretty it's not completely
smooth but in the next picture you're
going to see um the reason you do this
is it opens it up but what it also does
is it also allows for um
seed seeds to come up for weeds which
would allow more weeds to come up and
that's part of the thing too when you do
the no till you're not going to get as
many uh weed seeds that are on top and
weed and any seed needs the U sun to be
able to germinate so you want to make
sure you you control that and that's one
of the things they found out they have a
lot less weeds um not having as many
weeds you'll also find out when we talk
about fertilizers that that's better too
because you're not putting as much
synthetic things on the land which we
found out isn't that good here you can
see when they turn it um that they have
a this area right in here
uh that I circled with my
pointer that um it's a little bit higher
and that's the ridge it leaves there's
one across the second one here how those
are created is up here is where the disc
are it's just a a curved piece of metal
that's about u a foot and a half wide
and that's what actually goes into the
ground they have a hydraulic on it and
they are able to go into the ground that
far uh the farmer can lift it by a
control he has on his tractor
uh talking about synthetic fertilizers
um the synthetic fertilizers came about
around the time that they ended the
second world war and it was um
basically because we were farming we
weren't they needed to they always want
to increase production and that was a
way in which fertilizer of course um we
all use it on you know house plants we
have like um Miracle Grow
and it helps the plant grow it provides
nutrients that needs specifically
nitrogen that'll help that plant do
better most Farm crops nitrogen is um
the fertilizer they want to put on there
to make it grow better but one of the
problems that they found out um that
they didn't know right in the beginning
was that those synthetic fertilizers
don't make the soil Vitality any better
in other words the nutrients in the soil
that stay there they're they found out
that it uses it right away and then
there's nothing there so basically the
soil is getting worse and worse every
year the other thing is in a normal soil
there are
micronutrients and micronutrients aren't
in as large a supply as the
macronutrients that are out there and
nitrogen happens to be one of the
macronutrients um but basically they are
things that help a plant get stronger
they help a plant flower better um those
types of things and there's things like
Boron that um are some of the um
micronutrients but there's total of all
nutrients there's 17 different ones and
in a uh unit that's going to follow will
get into um all of the macro and
micronutrients so that'll make a lot
more sense then um also what happens is
that by putting in the fertilizers and
it's not a total result of that but
because you aren't building the soil and
the Vitality isn't as good it's going to
be become more compressed over time
because it's taking out some of those
nutrients um and it's going to not be
real good for the soil um one of the
other things they're found out is all
the nitrogens we put on the um on the
land when we're doing this there's times
that a lot of that fertilizer will leech
out that means it leaves it without
doing the desired effect that you want
with the fertilizer and basically what
happens is it goes from um the arm field
into ditches then to streams then to
rivers and it eventually gets down to
the Gulf of Mexico and basically what
happens on that is that's where all of
the U basically it's killing the coral
reefs and stuff um and all the uh all
the plants and animals that are at the
end of the Gulf of Mexico um and this
happens all over the world it's just not
in the Gulf of Mexico um but basically
what we're finding out is that we're
really putting too much on because if it
doesn't need it it just runs off the
other thing is if you put it on at the
wrong time uh if it rains sometimes rain
will make it wash away um if the water
is you know running off the field real
quickly um here's an example of a farmer
applying fertilizer and in this case
he's applying nitrogen and specifically
it's called anhydrous ammonia um it's a
it's a gaseous um liquid gas that BAS
basically if you breathe it um you would
probably not be here anymore uh it's
very dangerous um but basically what you
see and and it's a good example here if
you look at between the this is an
example of corn uh if you look between
it there's a residue from the corn of
last year um one of the things and we'll
we'll get into this in more detail as we
go through the course but that's one of
the problems they have that some of the
um crops we put in will put some
nutrients back into the soil Corn's not
one of those it actually just takes
nutrients especially nitrogen and that's
what's making the Vitality of the soils
uh less and less all the time and we'll
talk in ways we can make that better too
here's an example of um the the prior uh
slide showed you were just applying
nitrogen you apply it everywhere okay
it's really only needed where the plant
is but there's not an effective way we
can really do that without putting it on
the whole field here is an example of it
wouldn't so much be a farmer is not
going to be out there doing this but it
just shows that you can use a selective
weed killer even if you spray it on the
whole field but what's good about this
is it's only going to kill the uh
intended plant you want so if you're out
in a just say a grass yard um you can
spray a weed killer a selective weed
killer and it's not going to kill the
grass it's just going to Kill U the weed
that you want it's the same in a a farm
field they can put in selective
herbicides they call it it doesn't kill
the plant it only kills the weeds that
are
there
um for synthetic fertilizers um in in
some ways that it's it's become
something especially with corn that if
you don't use it you're not going to get
the crop yield that you want and and one
of the ways that they've made it they
they've used genetics to be able to
produce corn that that will give you uh
a yield that you like back in the 40s
and 50s they used to get about 40 to 45
um bushels of corn for an acre of land
right now they're exceeding 300 bushels
of corn per acre so you can see that
they've really really increased the
amount of uh yield you can get which
means you get more yield which means you
get more money and everyone loves it
part of the problem is is you needed a
lot of nitrogen to do that and because
you're putting more nitrogen there's
more runoff so you have a big issue with
that so that's some of the stuff that
we're going to start talking about what
can we do to become more sustainable
which you'll see is a huge word as we go
through this class um irrigation would
also aggravate the problem we talked
earlier when you get too much rain um
you can have an issue with it but but
with that is is that it'll make it run
off a little bit more you just have to
be careful with that irrigation isn't in
most Farms it's usually only in
Vegetable Farms um so if you're raising
stuff like potatoes or pumpkins or you
know peas or you know things you buy in
the store like that as opposed to corn
and um soybeans which are byproducts use
they create many different products but
they you don't eat that corn directly um
also irrigation aggravation a problem
that it adds salt to the soil and too
much salt is not good for soil either
and it doesn't necessarily go away salt
tends to stay it doesn't tend to um
leave the area and that could be a
problem and certainly is a problem in
some of the areas that do irrigation
um fertilizers are becoming
tremendously expensive um they didn't Ed
to be very expensive but even the
fertilizer you buy for your yard you
know 10 years ago used to be half the
cost of what it is today so that's
really made a big difference um and then
I talked earlier the the second to the
last point there is corn would not
produce what it does if you didn't
fertilize it you'd probably get about a
third the amount that you get currently
so you get about a 100 bushels an acre
as opposed to 300 and like we said when
we do that it doesn't address that
long-term Vitality of the soil because
what happens is it um just uses
everything that's there and no nutrients
are added and that's become a huge
problem okay um also besides doing the
nitrogens there's also chemicals that we
use for Pest and weed control um what
they try to control when they use these
chemicals are diseases that you might
get on crops um insect infestations um
and there's also the weeds you can get
um what we do is one of the reasons we
put the herbicides pesticides or
fungicides on and herbicides are for the
crops pesticides are things for like
grasshoppers bow weevils that type of
stuff the insects and fungicides are for
the diseases um that you might get and
it varies by crop and we'll talk a
little bit about that as we get into
suceeding chapters of uh this
course um so some of the issues we have
with the pest and weed control is that
it is a synthetic item so it's not
something that's natural and what we're
finding is is not having Natural Things
it isn't as good as we thought it was
but what happens is over time we have
found that the effectiveness of that
chemical decreases in other words it
isn't doing the same as it did because
the insects and diseases are learning
from their going to get killed with
let's say something like um DDT was a
perfect example it killed everything but
what we also found with that is over
time that it affected the environment
too so for the what one of the things of
DDT um affected tremendously were Birds
of Prey so the big thing everyone will
remember basically it's Hawks and Eagles
are birds of prey two of the big uh
species that are out there and we almost
lost all of the Eagles because what
happened is the shell of the egg got
thinner and thinner and thinner because
of
DDT and basically when the mother or
father Eagle sat on the eggs they broke
because they weighed too much um so now
that we got rid of DD in I believe it
was the 70s um the Eagles are making a
comeback as everyone knows um but one of
the issues with it is is that DDT was
was one of those chemicals that we
thought you put it on and did its job
and killed everything and then it went
away uh guess what that's not true the
DDT is still around and we haven't had
it on in what 40 years they haven't
applied any and it's still in soil so
we're finding out that some of the stuff
we're doing isn't so good and one of the
things we'll learn in this class is we
really really need to consider getting
away from synthetic as much as we can if
not totally
um here's just an example of irrigation
and excuse me here's a crop of it looks
like corn or potatoes it's hard to tell
it's so small um but basically they just
have those long units and they have
sprayers hanging off the the big uh
silver part that you see up here is how
the water goes across and that goes all
the way down there um the wheels on it
are so that they can have a motor we
don't see it in this picture but it
actually swings around on a pendulum and
it can go across that whole fields and
what you see here is those lines that
are there is where the tires going and
it actually uh ruins some of the crops
but it still um does a good job watering
and because you're watering it's in
areas they probably don't have enough
rain but things like corn and soybeans
don't need to have rain generally the
rain that you have in an area is enough
but when you get crops like the veggies
you really really need to have
irrigation because they need more a lot
more water
okay now we're going to start looking at
um how changes have started happening
over
time
um in terms of plants and animals is how
we're going to look at this changes
we've had in that they've had new
hybrids and varieties of crops every
year they come out with one of the ways
we're getting higher and higher yields
or the amount of crops we're pulling out
of a field each year is they come out
with new hybrids that will grow better
in either a specific area a specific
environment um or for a specific purpose
um we've all heard the the term GMO um
how they've accomplished this is they've
done the genetically modified organism
is what GMO stands for and that's how
they've come up with the new varieties
basically when back in the olden days I
guess I'll say they used to have what
they called open pollinated crops and
that was crops that basically if you
took like say an ear of corn and save
the corn the next spring you could plant
that corn and you get the same crop
again well they did that you know 40 45
bushel an acre and that wasn't enough it
wouldn't get anymore no matter what they
did so they started uh geneticists
started coming up with ways that they
could produce more uh corn uh so you had
larger uh cobs of corn ears of corn um
but when they did that what they're
finding out now is that that GMO type
stuff is starting to show up in the
animals that are um eating it it's
showing up in the people that are eating
the meat from the animals that are
eating the GMO corn so we're not sure
yet um what that means totally if it's
good or bad but we're beginning to
believe that perhaps the GMO might not
have been the right thing and we might
have to look at coming up with new
hybrids um that maybe aren't as genetic
Ally altered or certainly do studies to
find out whether or not it's affecting
us in a good or a bad way or animals
too um in terms of some of the stuff
there are new cross breeds of animals
and everyone's heard about the Clone
sheep and the Clone cattle you know the
the Betty the you know Barney whatever
the names of these animals are England
tends to be a place that has a lot of
they've come up with a lot of cloned
animals um basically what trying to do
when they do either a cloned animal or a
crossbreed is to pass on the desirable
traits from one let's say a cow to the
next one so in other words if there's
qualities about that cow it has too much
fat it's it it doesn't walk very well um
it has leaner um meat uh all those types
of things that they're going to pass
just those one traits that they like
onto it another thing is if if you had
dairy cattle that they would produce
more milk is the largest thing or you
produce a chicken that'll produce U more
meat or it'll lay more eggs that type of
thing um in order to do this though um
the what they do is they try to do these
things and then they'll use drugs and
medicines in order to help in that
development
um they aren't real sure at this point
and it's becoming more and more more of
a debate on whether or not these this
Evolution has been a great thing or it's
been a bad thing and it's it's I suppose
like anything you uh you're going to
have people that are on both sides of
the fence but time will tell on
that uh here's an example of one of the
things that in the in the what used to
always happen is here was an example
where you have cattle feed Lots okay
you're in a pasture on individual farms
and here's an example where um there's
not too many cattle here but in the
cattle feed Lots there are thousands and
thousands of cows and it's that um
corporate farming and then it's it's in
their opinion much cheaper to do that
but we've had some issues with um when
we've done that when you look at the
cattle feed Lots you see how close they
are together when the animals don't have
as much room to roam one of the issues
that they have is there's more pollution
because they're generally not out on
farms they're usually on the edge of
towns and they have nowhere to uh take
the animal waste and generally they just
keep piling it up and piling it up
whereas when it was on the Old Farm the
individual Family Farm they used to take
the um animal waste and spread it on the
fields and use that as fertilizer that
nitrogen um the other thing is when you
have animals in a small area they're
more prone to disease so therefore you
had to start using antibiotics that they
didn't use they have to use as much when
they're out on the individual Farms to
try to control the different um diseases
that they might
get um in terms of looking at these
changes that we're seeing that single
family farms are going away at an
alarming rate and a lot of it used to be
that the oldest son would always take
over um the family farm when Dad decided
to retire and Dad and Grandpa help out
on the farm but the son eventually had
it the oldest one and that's generally
what happened today it's pretty much all
of the children are leaving the farm and
when Dad retires they're selling the
farm and it's becoming larger and larger
and larger and more corporately owned um
and how stuff is done is totally based
on the kind of money you make not
necessarily what's good for the
environment um it's become also that
because the
um Cor corporate has kind of taken over
and made the large uh lots for raising
cattle that it isn't cost effective to
raise cows or pigs as much as it used to
be they aren't making as much uh in
terms of Dairy Farmers they have to pick
up the milk every day um and when you
had the 30 40 cows those type of farms
are pretty much going away and they're
you know setting Farms up with two three
four 5,000 dairy cows that they're uh
milking on a 24-hour operation so it's
become tremendously different um in in
in what's happening
um the last point there is most crops
are dependent on many factors and you
need ideal settings in order for them to
survive in other words that they're
becoming more and more specialized in
what they're able to do and how they
produce but what happens is if you get
out of that um environment that was
ideal you might not get the kind of uh
yield that you want to get so we've had
they're starting to have some issues
with that that they're trying to address
uh and then just a little bit a few
slides to talk about some of the
limitations that we have currently which
we've basically been talking about the
whole way through um what we're finding
out is that our model is not very
sustainable which means that over time
it isn't going to let you keep going on
and on and on we're going to have to
keep making changes add more fertilizer
you know add more pesticides or
herbicides or come up with new ones
because what we have isn't regenerating
what we need to have good example is the
uh nutrients in the soil that because we
don't have that it's not going to let us
continue on the way we're going
eventually we're going to have to change
that um another thing is populations are
growing cities are getting bigger so
every year the amount of land that we
Farm is
decreasing um and if you decrease the
land the only way that you're going to
produce enough food for everybody is to
increase the yield of what you're
growing um population growth of the
world is out of control they're saying
uh predictions are out there that by the
year 2050 that if population continues
to grow like it is right now they won't
have enough food to feed the world we'll
have massive
starvation um in the oceans um the
ecosystems there are declining over time
one of the problems is all the
fertilizers and pesticides and
herbicides are getting to the oceans and
it's starting to filter in and affect
the different uh flora and fauna that
are out there um and it's it's affecting
you know what we're going to have the
other thing they're having is in some
areas especially like on the East Coast
where they do a lot of uh
uh fishing where boats go out and get
all the different fish that are out
there and then in the Gulf of Mexico
they get all the um all the crabs and
the crabs
aren't aren't down there they're out
east but um the shrimp and those types
of uh uh animals that they're over
fishing now uh another problem we are is
we're coral reefs are dying due to that
fertilizer
population um they aren't excuse me they
aren't sure but they believe that the
GMO genetics um are starting to cause
pollution also and that's just in the
infancy of looking at that so we'll
learn more as time goes on of that um
another issue we have is the amount of
water we have the fresh water um you
can't use salt water from the oceans
which there's a ton of you have to use
fresh water so that's either comes from
a well the aquifers in the ground or
from lakes and ponds and what we're
using is increasing and increasing at an
alarming rate certainly faster than it's
being replenished in those aquifers
lakes and
ponds um also animal feed lots are
increasing in size so the pollution we
have the amount of uh uh medicines that
we have to give the animals and that is
increasing so that's all going to affect
our health as humans and things we want
to try to to uh reduce
that um what we're also learning is that
there's residues from the fertilizers
pesticides herbicides and insecticides
which um we use and what we need to do
is because it leeches out into the uh
water tables into the streams fonds and
rivers we need to reduce that um also
the uh the level of acid in the ocean is
increasing at a higher rate in other
words it's taking the oxygen out that it
has and it's destroying the coral floral
re from
in many areas which um they don't
totally understand all of those things
but they do know that everything around
it is affected by those coral reefs de
decreasing in size and coral reefs are
live uh organisms and they're dying at
an alarming rate all over the
world okay
um some of the limitations we have for
soil degradation and we using the
fertilizer what we're finding out it's
just taking the nutrients out um what it
also is doing is they call it their
nutrients are bound up in other words
the makeup of the soil is changing so
that the nutrients that that are there
are in a state that they aren't allowed
to be used in other words the soil's
keeping them and not letting the crops
use them so what's happening with that
that means that you're going to get less
of a crop yield um one of the things
they really believe to become
sustainable is that you have to get rid
of the monocropping what monocropping is
is that you're putting the same type of
plant in year after year after year
after year um it used to be over time
that um every third or fourth year they
used to rust the land and how you used
to rest the land is put in something
like wheat or oats or just don't put
anything in and put in some type of
cover crop with another possibility and
that put nitrogen back in the soils
those type of plants would put nitrogen
back back in and it used to be that they
one year they put soybeans the next year
they put corn the next year they uh put
in wheat and then they go through that
same cycle again and that would add the
nitrogen back into the soil which was
good because we don't do that anymore
and we're just putting on the synthetic
um fertilizer nitrogen um it's not it's
making the soil worse and worse and
worse as we go over time um other
problem is in the vegetable Fields we're
overwatering
and that's promoting that pollution by
salinization which is too much salt in
the soil and then um we're also over
grazing the pastures and basically what
that is you're putting too many animals
in a small area for the ones that are
grazing and they eat up all of the uh
crop or the grasses that are there and
therefore it's more expensive to feed
them um there's more disease it'll come
because it's all dirt uh the wind will
get the erosion issues so there's all
kinds of things that come into play um
when you're doing
that this is a list of all the
attributions um all the pictures we had
in here and where they're at so I'll
leave this up for a little bit so you
can see that